“Imagine a world millions of years in the
future.
Where evolution has written a new chapter
in the story of life.”
That was the tagline of ‘The Future is Wild,’
a miniseries that aired in the early 2000s
exploring the speculative lifeforms of the
far future.
And it was… amazing.
I think this show left an impact on a lot
of people — myself included.
I loved this series, and I think my interest
in it helped set me on the path which eventually
led to making this channel.
The special effects are, of course, a little
dated by today’s standards, but the world
is fantastically detailed, and an impressive
team of real scientists came up with the creatures
that inhabit it.
And while some of the predictions are pretty
out-there, people forget ‘The Future is
Wild’ never set out to flawlessly predict
future lifeforms — since that's impossible
— but to get people excited about biology
and earth science.
And I think these creatures definitely deserve
a nostalgic second look, even if you’ve
never heard of them before.
So, for this extra-long entry into the archive,
we’ll be exploring this hypothetical future
— having fun incorporating contemporary
scientific discoveries that might provide
new insight into these speculative lifeforms,
and just appreciating the richness of the
world the series created.
So, prepare to jump forwards several million
years — to the first era of ‘The Future
is Wild.’
The future is wild is divided into three eras
set 5 million, 100 million, and 200 million
years into the future.
Our journey begins in the 5-million-year era,
when Earth is locked in an ice age.
Humans aren’t present in this narrative,
having either left the planet or long since
died out.
We’d know this frozen wasteland as Northern
France, but it’s now unrecognizable — buried
under ice sheets over half a mile, or one
kilometer thick.
And stalking this icy tundra is the first
lifeform of the future.
This is a Snowstalker, a saber-toothed predator
searching desperately for a meal.
The scientists imagine Snowstalkers are the
descendants of wolverines, which have moved
from predator to apex predator thanks to an
available niche.
Essentially being a bigger and heavier version
of their ancestors — with the addition of
protruding saber teeth to take down large
prey — the Snowstalker is a grounded speculative
lifeform, and one of my favorites when I was
younger.
This snowstalker has journeyed all the way
to the coast in search of food.
And it might have found some in the form of
Gannetwhales.
Despite their size, these blubbery beach-dwellers
are actually aquatic birds, and have come
ashore to lay their eggs.
Their ancestor is the modern gannet, a bird
that can already dive underwater and swim
with its wings.
The concept of a gannet transitioning to a
dolphin-sized animal in just five million
years is in some ways surprising.
It might make more sense, for example, to
expect that already aquatic animals like sea
lions and penguins would be the ones to evolve
into a niche left by whales and their relatives.
But we now know better than ever from the
fossil record that whales themselves evolved
from a rodent-like animal into a large, sea-faring
one remarkably quickly.
So Gannetwhales, though unexpected, aren’t
impossible.
And while a single Gannetwhale would be a
mighty feast for a Snowstalker, this group
is just too large to be worth the trouble.
Further inland, however, another potential
source of food is moving across the plains.
On the horizon, a herd of Shagrats slog their
way through the snow.
These thick-coated creatures are the descendants
of Alpine Marmets, although the Shagrats are
over three times larger than their rodent
ancestors.
And while Shagrats look a bit like musk oxen,
they aren’t much bigger than sheep, so five
million years is plenty of time for such a
lifeform to emerge upon the tundra.
Yet Shagrats aren’t big enough to deter
a predator like a Snowstalker.
All it takes is for one of them to fall behind
the herd, and the weary Snowstaker can at
last get its meal.
Yet this meal won’t just feed one mouth.
This particular Snowstalker is a mother, and
is bringing back food for her two cubs.
The moment here always stuck out to me — as
it shows us that even in the most competitive
ecosystems, parental instincts haven’t changed.
But other ecosystems are even more barren.
The scientists imagine that to the south,
tectonic and temperature shifts have transformed
the Mediterranean Sea into vast salt flats.
Dashing along this harsh expanse is a Cryptile.
These lizards are some of the only creatures
that can endure this arid desert thanks to
their clever method of getting moisture.
Near pools of brine, enormous swarms of Brine
Flies reproduce and take to the air.
These engorged flies are an excellent source
of food and water for anything that can catch
them.
And the Cryptile is an expert fly-trapper.
The lizard rushes through the huge swarm of
flies, using its neck-frill as a fishing net,
and licking the trapped flies off the net
as it runs.
It’s an extreme concept for a lifeform,
but a believable one.
The Cryptile, like a lot of the best lifeforms
in ‘The Future is Wild,’ takes numerous
unique traits from modern animals — such
as frilled lizards and salt-lake ground-dragons
— and combines them into a new, yet still
plausible lifeform.
Rising out of the salt, the Mediterranean
islands are now mountains of eroded limestone
rock.
For Cryptiles, they make for an ideal egg-laying
location.
Deep fissures in the rock called grykes mark
the island’s surface, and some of these
miniature canyons are narrow enough that they
are inaccessible to most predators.
But near the larger grykes, a Cryptile needs
to be on its guard.
For there is a predator here — a stealthy
Gryken that takes advantage of the natural
cover the grykes provide.
The Grykens’ closest ancestor is the pine
marten, a small predator that today navigates
the branches of trees instead of narrow canyons.
But five million years is a reasonable stretch
of time for a pine marten to become a deadly
Gryken.
Efficient as Grykens are, however, the Cryptile
has the advantage of speed…
A Cryptile isn’t the preferred prey of the
Grykens, though.
Instead, the delicate looking pigs known as
Scrofas are their primary food source.
At a glance, it’s easy to tell the Scrofas
are the descendants of wild boars, but with
one distinct change.
Scroffa leg bones have become elongated, with
the animals now walking on the tips of their
toes.
It’s an adaptation we’ve documented elsewhere
in nature.
This hoof design mirrors those of Klipspringer
antelopes, which have similar ballet-shoe
like hooves to move on rocky outcroppings.
So, considering the Scrofa’s environment,
their strange hoof structure holds up to scrutiny.
With pigs this athletic, the Grykens have
their work cut out for them in trying to catch
one.
Further south is one of the regions I remember
most distinctly from my childhood.
Huge grassy plains stretch across the South
American landscape where the Amazon Rainforest
stood before the ice age.
And upon this Amazon prairie, a strange troop
of ground-dwelling monkeys called Babookaries
move through tall grass.
The Babookaries are fairly intelligent, weaving
strange basket-like traps and placing them
in shallow lakes to catch small fish, which
are their primary food source.
While this level of tool use in a primate
might be surprising, we now have even more
documentation than when this documentary aired
of primates using tools to get their food.
But the monkey the Babookari are theoretically
evolved from — the red-faced uakari — aren’t
among those documented using basic tools.
Capuchin monkeys might be the more expected
ancestor to the plains dwelling Babookari,
as they’re already transitioning in the
present day to a less-arboreal lifestyle,
and use stones to break open food.
But no matter their ancestor, the Babookari’s
existence on the plains is imagined to be
quite perilous.
For the troop is always in danger of being
eaten by the mighty Carakillers, enormous
predatory birds that patrol the grasslands
in groups.
Like the Babookari, the Carakiller’s ancestor
is a bit surprising, as they’re imagined
to have evolved from small falcons in just
five million years’ time.
A larger modern bird like the red-legged seriema
— whose ancestors, the terror birds, are
the real-world inspiration of the Carakiller
— are another potential starting point for
these giants.
But in either case, Carakillers — for all
their strength — can’t do much to a creature
like a Rattleback.
These reptile-like armored omnivores are imagined
to have too thick a shell for a Carakiller
to break through.
Their ‘armor’ is actually derived from
hair, which has become matted and fused into
hard scales.
This is because the Rattleback isn’t a reptile
at all, but a mammal, imagined to have evolved
from a forest dwelling rodent species.
They were another of my favorites from this
era — although admittedly a rodent transitioning
to a reptile-like creature that can move its
scales independently in just five million
years would be quite the transformation.
But a relative of the Rattleback that is closer
to its mammalian ancestor dwells in the bleak
desert of central North America.
In this ice age desert, the North American
Rattleback braves the intense cold.
This particular Rattleback is a mother traveling
with her baby, and they are facing the intense
winds of a sandstorm.
Luckily, their spines aren’t just adapted
to deter predators, but also to protect themselves
from the unforgiving environment.
These creatures are more what one might expect
to emerge in this evolutionary timeframe.
To find food, the rattlebacks dig underground
for tubers.
But this mother is unknowingly disturbing
the burrow of a highly unusual subterranean
lifeform.
This tiny creature is a Spink, and although
it may not look like it, the Spink is a bird.
According to the documentary, the Spink evolved
from quails, near-flightless birds that transitioned
to an underground lifestyle.
The Spink are another creature that seems
unusually specialized for just five million
years of transition — although we do have
documentation of other birds, like bee eaters,
creating burrows in which to lay their eggs.
But the Spink live almost their entire lives
in their tunnels, and only come out under
cover of darkness.
Peculiar as they are, I’ve always found
these tunneling birds strangely adorable…
Far less adorable are the creatures that swoop
overhead.
With wingspans of 4 feet, or one meter, these
predators, called Deathgleaners, look like
giant predatory birds.
But these are actually bats, which have evolved
to take the spot of apex predators of the
North American skies.
It would take a very special extinction event
for bats to outcompete large North American
birds of prey like eagles and condors.
But certain modern species of bats like flying
foxes have already reached similar sizes — so
from a biomechanical perspective, given the
right opportunity, creatures like the Deathgleaners
could indeed take flight…
Yet five million years into the future isn’t
the only speculative era ‘The Future is
Wild’ explores.
The documentary then jumps to my personal
favorite era 100 million years into the future.
Beginning in the coastal swamps, this is a
version of Earth where hot and humid climate
conditions have led to a period of tremendous
biodiversity.
And no species is more emblematic of this
era of abundance than the Toraton.
These lumbering giants are huge — described
as being the largest land animals ever, exceeding
the weight of even the biggest dinosaur.
So, it’s surprising that the ancestor of
these creatures is a species of tortoise.
Tortoises might not be the most expected lifeform
to break the size record, especially since
we now have better research suggesting that
large dinosaurs like sauropods could only
get so large thanks to their starting advantage
of lightweight bone construction.
Still, I always loved the concept of giant
tortoises, and other aspects of the Toraton
— like legs that have shifted to under their
body, and their swampy environment having
a tremendous amount of available plant matter
-- make a lot of sense considering their size.
Near the feet of the Toratons dwell a family
of Swampus.
These excellently named creatures are the
descendants of octopuses, and remarkably,
they can move on land.
Strange as this might sound, we now have more
documentation than ever of octopuses moving
upon the land in a limited capacity, using
their tentacles to haul themselves along.
The Swampus takes this concept further by
being able to breathe above water to some
extent, sort of like the strange mudskippers
of today.
And like the mudskipper, the Swampus spend
part of their time in the water, and aren’t
true land-dwelling cephalopods.
Those will come later…
And every time the Swampus returns to the
water, it has to be on high alert.
For there’s an apex predator here in the
murky depths that can feed on the Swampus.
This is a Lurkfish, a descendant of the catfish
that can sense the Swampus’s movement thanks
to a weak electric field the Lurkfish generates.
But this terror of the wetland has another
use for electricity.
Releasing a powerful shock, the Lurkfish stuns
the Swampus, and swallows its meal in a single
gulp.
While this menacing lifeform might seem far-fetched,
many modern catfish hunt in a manner that
is surprisingly similar.
Certain species of catfish can produce a small
shock thanks to specialized muscles on their
backs, which the catfish uses to stun its
prey just like a Lurkfish…
But it’s not just the swamps of this era
that the documentary imagines are much changed.
Higher global temperatures have caused tremendous
sea level rise, with many lowland regions
now flooded.
These vast, shallow seas stretch across the
globe — and are home to remarkable new lifeforms.
This is an Ocean Phantom.
Always one of my favorites, this complex looking
creature is a unique type of siphonophore.
Like modern siphonophores, the Ocean Phantom
is actually composed of numerous different
lifeforms, some which act as sails to help
it navigate these seas, some which help keep
the lifeform afloat, and some which trail
below the colony to help catch food.
The idea of a lifeform using biological sails
might sound a little out there, but some modern
siphonophores and their relatives have already
evolved something similar.
So, while the Ocean Phantom is certainly an
unusual lifeform, frankly, so are most modern
siphonophores…
Under the water’s surface, small creatures
swim in the shallow current.
At a glance, these creatures look like fish,
but the scientists imagine they’re actually
a descendent of sea slugs, or nudibranch.
These are Reef Gliders, and they play a vital
role in pollinating the red algae that grows
here.
Free swimming sea slugs might have once seemed
far-fetched, but the recently-filmed Cephalopyge
is a nudibranch that has evolved to spend
its entire life swimming in the ocean current.
So, the concept of a fish-like sea slug such
as the Reef Glider isn’t so unlikely after
all.
But the Reef Gliders are in danger here in
the open ocean.
For the Ocean Phantom is a hunter, and is
quite adept at snatching up Reef Gliders and
using them to feed the colony.
But feeding on small Reef Gliders is a dangerous
gambit, for while young Reef Gliders are small,
adults are large enough to pose a serious
threat to the soft Ocean Phantom.
Yet in cases where the colony is menaced by
an adult Reef Glider, the Ocean Phantom has
one last form of protection.
It has its own personal defense team, in the
form of Spindle Troopers.
Huge sea spiders that live in the chambers
of the phantom rush to defend it.
They attack the huge adult Reef Glider, until
it backs off.
The highly complex symbiosis between the Spindle
Troopers and the Ocean Phantoms have modern
parallels; as the documentary points out,
body guards aren’t unheard of in nature.
The trapezoid crab lives among coral, and
protects its home from coral-eating starfish
with its sharp pinchers.
The Ocean Phantoms take this a step further,
however, by also providing the Spindle Troopers
with sustenance produced from red algae that
grows on the Ocean Phantoms back.
Truly, these siphonophores are almost like
miniature cities floating on the fast shallow
seas…
Not all regions of this high-temperature Earth
are underwater.
A vast rainforest can be found upon a rather
unexpected continent.
We know this landmass as Antarctica — but
it has changed much from our era, becoming
warmer and warmer as tectonic plate shifts
caused the landmass to shift upward.
Now, near the equator, this green Antarctica
has given rise to startling adaptations.
Birds are the main inhabitants of this region,
as they were some of the few animals able
to migrate to this island continent over the
millennia.
But this particular species — the Spitefire
bird — has a defense unlike any we’d recognize.
When threatened, the Spitefire Bird sprays
a hot, noxious fluid from its nose.
While we’ve never seen such a defense evolve
in a bird in our time, the bombardier beetle
can produce a burning, acid-like substance
that can repel almost any predator.
The Spitefire Bird might just be the most
impressive bird species of the Green Antarctic.
On the nearby peaks of the Great Plateau,
however, another remarkable species is waiting.
The mountain range where it dwells was formed
by the tectonic plates of Australia and South
Eastern Asia colliding — a crash that would
likely result in peaks even higher than the
Himalayas of today.
And soaring over these peaks is a Great Blue
Windrunner.
This giant bird possesses a wingspan of almost
ten feet, or three meters.
And upon closer inspection, it actually has
four wings, not just two, to help it maintain
altitude.
At the time of ‘The Future is Wild’s’
production, the concept of a bird with four
wings was just speculation.
After its release, however, a specimen of
the dinosaur genus Microraptor was discovered
to have had four wings, just like the Windrunner.
While the Microraptor is of course a lifeform
from Earth’s past instead of its future
— this discovery shows such a body plan
was, at one point, successful.
While the Windrunners are majestic, a much
less appealing species lurks in the gloom
of the Great Plateau’s caves.
These are Silver Spiders, massive arachnids
that have collected huge piles of grass seeds.
But Silver Spiders are carnivores.
The seeds aren’t for them.
They’re for a small, shy form of rodent.
The amusingly named Poggle.
While the hamster-like Poggles themselves
are cute, their role in this ecosystem gave
me more existential dread during my childhood
than… pretty much anything.
The documentary imagines the Poggles are,
unsettlingly, the very last of all mammal
species on earth.
And while the Silver Spiders allow them to
eat their fill of seeds, this is because the
Spiders are farming the Poggles.
In moderation, the spiders attack one Poggle…
and drag it off to be eaten.
It’s a terrifying fate for the last mammal,
and one which I’m sure caused nightmares
across the globe.
Thankfully, it’s probably one of the less
likely hypotheticals.
Mammals are highly adaptable — having already
survived one mass extinction, and aren’t
likely to be outcompeted so thoroughly in
all parts of the globe — even in a hundred
million years.
But a world without mammals is an interesting
concept to explore as a hypothetical, which
is part of the idea behind ‘The Future is
Wild’ anyway…
200 million years into the future, we’ve
reached the final era of ‘The Future is
Wild,’ which the scientists imagine is home
to the most unrecognizable lifeforms of all.
This version of Planet Earth now features
a single super continent, and a single global
ocean — much like the bygone era of Pangea.
This is indeed where our tectonic plates are
likely heading, and the result would be some
truly extreme environments.
On the edge of the coast, what seem like birds
are flapping in the sky.
But upon closer inspection, these aren’t
birds, but aerial fish, which the documentary
amusingly calls ‘Flish.’
The Flish are the icon of the franchise in
a way, and are meant to have evolved from
the gliding flying fish of today.
In 200 million years, such a lifeform evolving
more efficient flight and lung-like organs
isn’t so improbable a hypothetical after
all.
And the air is one of the safer places to
be, for in the waters of the global ocean,
sharks are still patrolling.
This bioluminescent species is a Sharkopath
— another entertaining name.
Sharks surviving this far into the future
with essentially the same body plan makes
complete sense, as they’ve been stalking
our oceans for at least 400 million years
with few changes.
But the introduction of bioluminescent signals
shows the Sharkopaths have become coordinated
pack hunters — using their flashes to keep
track of each other during a hunt.
But while the Sharkopaths are deadly, they
aren’t the largest lifeforms in the Global
Ocean.
That distinction goes to the colossal Rainbow
Squid.
These highly intelligent lifeforms are another
one of my childhood favorites, due to their
ability to change color to ward off predators.
Displays like this are also present in the
cephalopods of today thanks to the power of
Chromatophores.
These are pigment filled sacs in the skin
that can create remarkably complex colors
and patterns in response to signals from the
animal’s brain.
But the Rainbow Squid’s Chromatophores are
imagined to be on another level, able to render
the creature virtually invisible by matching
the color of the water — or light up the
Rainbow Squid in a dazzling display to others
of their kind…
A squid offshoot one day conquering the sea
is one thing.
But on land, ‘The Future is Wild’ has
one last surprise.
This perpetually damp rainforest is located
on the northwestern portion of the era’s
supercontinent.
And lumbering through the forest is a sixteen-foot,
or five meters tall . . . squid.
This is a Megasquid — one of the most famous
and debated lifeforms of ‘The Future is
Wild.’
Like the Swampus, it’s a cephalopod that
has traded the sea for the land, but unlike
the swampus, is now fully terrestrial.
Even in 200 million years, a squid becoming
an elephant sized land-dweller without a rigid
skeleton seems improbable.
The documentary claims the squid supports
itself using a network of circular and vertical
muscles that act as a pseudoskeleton.
And according to calculations done by McNeill
Alexander, a late British biomechanist who
worked on the project, the math actually checks
out in favor of the megasquid.
So, the Megasquid, while extremely speculative,
might not be completely impossible after all.
Which is a preferable outcome — because
the concept of a giant, forest dwelling squid
is amazing.
And in the branches above the Megasquid, the
final creature of ‘The Future is Wild’
is waiting.
This is a Squibbon: another type of terrestrial
squid that spends its life swinging from the
branches of the forest canopy.
And if that isn’t strange enough, the documentary
imagines that navigating the three-dimensional
forest has made these creatures highly intelligent.
Indeed, this 200-million-year journey ends
with a stirring promise of human-like intelligence
reemerging through the Squibbon.
It’s a speculative concept that is certainly
unusual, but strangely compelling.
While humans are gone forever in this future,
the implication that a new civilization of
intelligent squids will replace us . . . is
perhaps strangely comforting.
I could explore this world forever, and while
there’s not enough time to cover every single
lifeform — I hope I’ve shown why ‘The
Future is Wild’ was something really special.
There wasn’t anything like it on TV at the
time, and there hasn’t really been anything
quite like it since.
Hearing top scientists get excited about the
creatures they’ve invented was just so…
wholesome.
And I hope they know how much the world they
created meant to people.
I hear there have been plans to revive the
show that have never quite materialized, and
I think that’s a shame.
I feel like a modern remake or sequel with
better effects and even more science would
really be successful in the age of the internet.
Maybe one day we’ll get more of The Future
is Wild, but in the meantime, we have the
incredible original, which has stood the test
of time.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.